at the beginning of the movie we are
shown the surroundings inside a prison
where a police officer named green is
assigned to the task of delivering money
to a high-profile prisoner while green
is preparing the stash of money we are
introduced to the prisoner balam he is a
notorious drug lord who carries out all
of the illegal activities like drug
trafficking human organs smuggling and
weapon transport despite being
incarcerated inside prison balham
actually stays in this prison Because he
believes it's the safest place where his
enemies can't reach him and he can
smoothly run all the illegal trades
without being caught balham has access
to Five Star level facilities inside the
prison with his personal guards and
assistance in the next scene new
prisoners including an ex-officer named
Jack Stone are brought in and are
informed that they will be housed in the
same building as balam while each of
them is being inspected and sent to
their respective cells officer green
stops Jack on the way and physically
assaults him he hits him with a baton on
his stomach and also berates him for
killing a fellow police officer before
walking away green warns back that he
will give him a hard time inside the
prison so that he won't last long the
story then flashes back a week before
when Jack and his fellow officers rob a
bank as planned unbeknownst to others
their real motive was to gather
incriminating evidence against balam
corrupt government officials and police
officers involved in different criminal
activities after successfully acquiring
the evidence from the bank lockers they
attempt to flee the scene but are
intercepted by other officers in the
ensuing confrontation Jack's colleagues
gets shot and die on the spot however
Jack somehow manages to flee and seeks
Refuge inside a building with some
officers in Pursuit later as Jack
attempts to escape the area he is
confronted by an officer who threatens
to kill him however Jack surprises the
officer by revealing his face and then
jumping from the building taking the
officer with him here it is revealed
that the officer was responsible for
Jack's wife's murder both of them lie
flat on the floor and the officer
immediately passes away after surviving
the deadly fall Jack discreetly leaves a
bag in front of the apartment of a
reporter named Trisha the bag contains
the evidence of corrupt government
officials involving Balaam in a letter
Jack urges Trisha to report the case to
the district attorney's office fast
forward to the present Jack finds
himself incarcerated alongside an inmate
named Silva later during lunch balaam's
cousin's Semion approaches his table and
confronts him demanding Security money
however Jack refuses and this results in
a scuffle between the two parties to
everyone's surprise he easily takes down
Semion and his men following this Jack
is taken to a secret prison where he is
contacted by balam via security cameras
balum warns Jack to stop meddling in his
Affairs or else he will meet a fate like
his deceased wives however balance
threats have no effect on Jack as he
listens to them unfazed later that night
three of bellum's henchmen try to attack
Jack and his cell but to their surprise
he quickly wakes up and subdues them
without even disturbing his sleeping
soulmate Silva on the other hand Trisha
diligently investigates the evidence she
received from Jack and tries to gather
more information about the person I'll
mentioned there after putting in some
effort she also uncovers Jack Stone's
real identity the next day armed with
sufficient proof Trisha arrives at the
attorney's office and talks to the
receptionist to arrange a meeting in
person with
however the receptionist informs her
that he is busy and she cannot meet him
as an alternative she suggests Trisha
hand over the evidence to the attorney's
assistant Mark however Trisha does not
trust him with the evidence so she walks
out of the office that evening she waits
for the attorney to exit his office
hoping she can have a face-to-face
meeting and submit the evidence when the
district attorney general Johnson
finally walks out Trisha quickly
approaches him without wasting any time
she reveals all the evidence against the
corrupt officials and police officers to
him impressed with her determination and
the collection of evidence Johnson
Praises her gives her his personal card
and urges her to call him if she needs
any assistance in the next scene Trisha
makes her way to the prison to meet Jack
and shares the news that she's actively
using the information he provided her in
response Jack tells her that she's on
the right track and advises her to be
cautious with the evidence soon after he
is approached by an older inmate named
William who warns him about the dangers
of Crossing balham's men however Jack
boldly declares that he isn't afraid of
anyone he then inquires about balaam's
cell location but William explains that
it's a closely guarded secret known to
only a few prison guards elsewhere we
are shown a female prison where two
inmates engage in a heated fight the
confrontation in the cafeteria is so
intense that the guards are forced to
intervene and separate them one of the
fighting inmates is Elena and she is
later Taken to Balaam with her face
covered with a black mask upon reaching
balance luxurious prison Alina notices
other prisoners also present there she
is brought there because she engaged in
a fight with one of balaam's favorite
female prisoners to everyone's surprise
Balaam announces that they need to
eliminate Jack to claim a hefty reward
of a hundred thousand dollars following
balaam's offer the prisoners unite and
launch an attack on Jack while he's
engaged in conversation with William
however they have no idea that Jack
himself is a trained officer and with
the help of William he skillfully
counters the assault defeating all the
attackers meanwhile balham receives an
alarming call from Attorney Johnson who
discloses Trisha's possession of
incriminating evidence against him
Johnson also mentions that she has such
detailed information that no attorney
can Overlook enraged balum instructs
Johnson to take care of Trisha
immediately while he himself plans to
eliminate Jack by day's end later during
Jack's laundry time a group of prison
guards storm in determined to claim the
rewards set by balam Jack initially
finds himself outnumbered and suffers
blows from the guard's batons thinking
that he will get into trouble for
attacking police officers but when he
learns that they are only after the
reward he summons his courage and fights
back one by one Jack takes all the
corrupt officers down however as he
leaves the laundry area another group of
prisoners confronts him ready to attack
Jack attempts to reason with them
explaining that the promised prize isn't
worth the risk especially when divided
among all of them surprisingly his logic
strikes a chord and the prisoners
reconsider deciding to back off in the
meantime Trisha meets her friend Alison
asking for help she confides in her
sharing all the intricate details about
Balaam the evidence and the corrupt
officials involved in the criminal
Network after listening to the details
Allison agrees to help her back in the
female prison Alina attempts to
reconcile with balam's favorite prisoner
cat however the latter isn't forgiving
and she instigates another brawl Landing
a punch in Elena's face faking
unconsciousness Selena lies on the floor
and is taken to the prison doctors for
further examination as the doctor leaves
to attend to other matters Elena
skillfully opens her handcuffs using a
paper clap secretly put some alcohol and
Medicine in William's cleaning bucket
and takes a key to the air vent from
there she then enters the air vent and
finds her way to the CCTV camera room
before returning to the medical room she
draws a map of the path on her stomach
the next day Trisha again arrives at the
prison to converse with Jack she claims
that she has gathered a significant
amount of information regarding his past
she then confronts him about the killing
of a fellow officer seeking an
explanation Jack decides to trust Trisha
and reveals the painful truth behind the
incident his wife was brutally murdered
by balaam's men who also included the
police officer he killed later Jack
shockingly discovers that William whom
he had considered just another inmate is
actually an undercover officer he asks
him about the duration of his duty and
William shares that he has been working
covertly for six months with a mission
to expose the corrupt prisoners and
government officials working with Balaam
to achieve this he has partnered with
Alina who is also working undercover
within the prison trying to uncover
hidden evidence and balaam's networks
while Jack is listening to William's
Revelation the two suddenly find
themselves under attack by other
prisoners a fierce fight breaks out and
amidst the chaos Jack is falsely accused
of instigating the brawl as a
consequence he is thrown into solitary
confinement as punishment leaving him
isolated and Confused elsewhere William
is summoned to meet Blaine the prison
Warden who has a history of clashing
with balaam's man aware of William's
intentions he takes advantage of the
situation and threatens to expose him
unless he provides more money meanwhile
Trisha persists in her efforts to meet
the district attorney Johnson but his
busy schedule keeps him away from her
one day the attorney's assistant Mark
approaches Trisha and pressures her to
hand over the evidence she has gathered
against balam and his associates however
still does not give in and walks out
from there later in the prison balham's
daughter arrives to meet him leading to
his temporary release and transfer to
the meeting chamber William spots balham
as he exits his cell and signals Elena
to initiate their plan as soon as she
gets the signal Alina pretends to faint
diverting the attention of the guards
and compelling one of them to carry her
to the doctor while on the way she and
William take down the guard gaining
control over the CCTV room and prison
operations following this William
observes through the surveillance
cameras that balam is about to leave the
visiting room quick on his feet he
unlocks Jack's solitary confinement cell
and sets him free Jack determines to
take down balam incapacitates a prison
guard and disguises himself in the
guard's uniform with William and Alina
guiding him from the CCTV room Jack
follows their instructions to navigate
the prison stealthily and reach balam's
private cell before he returns the
stakes are high but they are determined
to expose balam's criminal Empire and
bring the corrupt officials to Justice
shortly after Blaine and several prison
guards discover an unauthorized entry
into the CC TV room they attempted to
access the room while Alina finds a
clever Escape Route through the
ventilation docks realizing that balam
is being heavily guarded by prison
guards and their time is running out
before he returns to his cell William
does something drastic he decides to
create chaos by unlocking all the prison
cells allowing the enraged prisoners to
retaliate against the guards who
mistreated them officer green tries to
flee but is stopped by Jack who shoves
him into a group of vengeful prisoners
on the other hand William and Alina
engage in Fierce battles with the
attacking inmates Jack somehow makes his
way towards balance prison cell and
confronts Semion the two engage in a
brutal fight and Semion stabs Jack with
a knife but despite the injury our hero
digs down deep and ultimately defeats
his opponent before proceeding to
balance chamber meanwhile a shocking
Revelation unfolds outside the prison
Alison who had promised to help Trisha
is actually working for the corrupt
Attorney Johnson she hits her friend and
points a gun at her following Johnson's
orders however before Allison can I'm
Tricia mark an undercover FBI agent
posing as a prosecutor's assistant
intervenes to save her here it is
revealed that Mark is on a mission to
expose the corrupt to District Attorney
Johnson and other government officials
involved in the conspiracy back at the
prison Williams successfully
incapacitates Warden Blaine and the
remaining guards while Jack enters
balance prison he faces off with balum
in a fierce one-on-one battle but the
latter gains the upper hand and knocks
him down however Jack finds the strength
to rise again fueled by the memory of
his wife's tragic death at the hands of
balaam's men with renewed determination
he defeats balham avenging his beloved
wife next the SWAT team arrives just in
time to regain control of the chaotic
situation once the dust settles William
introduces Jack and Alina to each other
expressing gratitude for their
collaboration and dismantling balham's
criminal Empire from both inside and
outside the prison Jack in turn thanks
the duo for their invaluable assistance
in achieving his long-awaited revenge as
a result of the investigation the FBI
arrest all corrupt government officials
and police officers who were
collaborating with balam in the last
scene Jack is taken into custody by
William with the promise of a swift
release in a short period of Time the
movie then ends with a sense of justice
served and the eradication of the
malevolent forces that once plagued both
the prison and Society at large
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching